the one october anniversary is a little
over a month away and many survivors are
still healing part of that healing is
gathering to share feelings and honor
those lost in the harvest festival
shooting the vegas strong 5k brings
thousands of people together to run and
remember
[Applause]
this was just weeks after the harvest
festival shooting in 2017
thousands of people gathered for the
first ever vegas strong 5k the community
came together to run carrying their
emotional scars and memories of that
october night
cynthia gainey organized the event
planning to have just one 5k to raise
money for victims
but then people kept saying we want this
to continue every year every year and i
said i will continue to put it on as
long as people want it and
it just you know when i look at the
registration i mean we have 20 of the
people that are registered so far are
from out of nevada so people want to be
here they want to come together and
remember
well the first two years brought more
than 3 000 people together to honor the
memory of those lost and help survivors
heal registrations come from all over
the u.s and as far away as canada and
the uk
last year's 5k was completely virtual
though thanks to the pandemic but still
more than a thousand people signed up
cynthia says one october has made the
city stronger
when it happens in your home
whether you know somebody or not i mean
you stick together unconditionally and i
think that's what
that's what we have um
you know what vegas has done uh based on
this tragedy it's putting one step in
front of the other
to
get to get over to get over it basically
to you know put yourself back up get
back up and uh continue on living but
that's what i've heard a lot of is that
that's what this event does it's like it
forces them to get out there put what
one foot in front of the other so they
can get through it
but never forget
exactly exactly
and we never will
well all of the proceeds of the event
will be donated to several organizations
to help survivors and victims families
the vegas strong resiliency center the
healing garden downtown a scholarship
fund for victims children and a
scholarship program for high school
students who want to pursue a career as
a first responder now you can sign up
for the vegas strong 5k on the just run
website link that you see right here the
event will be october 3rd at floyd land
park in the northwest valley and there
is a limit of 750 who can gather in
person but no limit to virtual
registration
and so cynthia says people have already
been signing up virtually who still just
aren't quite comfortable yet coming
together uh but so far i mean the
registrations are going pretty quickly
but there's still more than a hundred
spots left for in person okay uh but she
says you know she feels like by the end
of this year and she didn't plan on
doing i mean this will be the fourth
vegas strong 5k now
that she will have raised almost a
quarter of a million dollars for those
organizations yeah so it really has made
a big difference and didn't you say that
she's got folks registering from out of
town who obviously were aware of the
incident and do want to come here and be
part of the in-person room yes i mean
she's got at least 20 people that have
registered from canada
and there was one person lost in the
shooting from canada
and so and a lot of people 25 states
that have registered people from 25
states it's fun to be a part of it
whether you can do it in person or
whether you do it virtually especially
knowing that the money goes to such
important causes here because even
though it's been almost four years now
there are still many there's a lot of
healing that still has to happen a lot
of counseling a lot of just assistance
that is still ongoing so it's a fun
event too we really urge you if you
haven't gone downtown to the healing
garden oh yeah it really is an
experience and they've upgraded it a lot
there's a it's it's much more up well
kept now there's a big a nice wall there
that has a lot of different things too
they have a little waterfall in the back
so it's a nice place to stop by it's
very poignant peaceful yeah